[Music]
now you keep your relationship with
Stevie Nicks romantic relationship on
the down-low from Tom Petty yeah you
want Tom Petty to know that he's your
boy yeah you're focused on him it's
almost like dealing with another lover
you don't want Tom Petty to find out
that you're dating Stevie Nicks I'm
working on her album that's because
he'll think you're not putting your
energies right I was 100% Tom Petty so
you came up with a brilliant plan I'm
gonna hide Stevie Nicks in my basement
yes when every Tom Petty comes around
daddy's [ __ ] crazy how do you get her
to go down into the basement and hide I
said see me look together BAM
Tom doesn't know you I I'm his best my
best friend but don't treat your best
friend like that like a [ __ ] idiot I
was
I just kept making social mistakes in my
career I was doing better musically but
I made more more so she was like so I
said do me a favor
the basements like a set of basements
nice is when he comes to stay down there
you know but then you come up with
another brilliant idea
you said Stevie you should sing with Tom
stop draggin my heart around you guys
should record this together for your
album yeah what a [ __ ] idea well what
what happened was I said to her CD you
have this beautiful album but no hits no
one's going to hear it quickly with no
hits on right I said no we're going to
hit this thing it's going to come out
you can have the candles all over the
[ __ ] cover leis shawls on that on the
lamps and I said you know and twirling
and no one's going to get the goddamn
album so she gets pissed at me and I
said but here's a song and again I went
back to that same thing I said if a
woman sing an aggressive guy's lyric I
can't miss you had Stevie Nicks singing
they make a meal of some bright-eyed kid
you need someone to look after you a
woman saying that to her man can't miss